you guys it's the first table read of
season five today
the cast of fuller house is back and
hard at work on their fifth and final
season without Laurie Lachlan
I mean Aunt Becky today is literally
like yeah hug everybody
and everybody asks the same question how
is your happiness how is your biggest
your bigges Jodie Sweetin shared this
pic on Instagram Wednesday
that's her holding the script with the
caption we're back and if you look
closely you can see the title for the
first episode of season 5 welcome home
baby to be named later I'm always
constantly in tears because of my love
for Candace Cameron Bure also took to
social media to dish on their return to
set and got pretty emotional about it
I'm back in my dressing room on the set
of fuller house and I'm a mess we had
our first table reading this morning and
I cried through the whole thing because
I this I love the people I work with so
much and I love this show so much and
it's gonna be such a great season but
it's gonna be really hard emotionally
I'm like oh it's awful I'm crying at the
drop of a hat
miss Kimmy Gibbler herself Andrea barber
vlogged about the first day back on set
giving a behind-the-scenes look at what
the day looked like here we are we're
going to stage 24 this is our last first
so it's a little bittersweet but it's
also very very exciting it's so exciting
to hear what is going on this season
there's a lot when we left off a baby
had just been born and a proposal had
just been made so I'm very excited to
see where Bob Saget was also at the
table so it's safe to say we can expect
to see Danny Tanner in episode 1 all
jokes aside Bob actually got a little
choked up talking about the final season
at the table with the cast I'm so proud
to have been able to raise these girls
and know them since they were like my
girls like my own daughters I mean one
kid when they should have started that I
didn't like her it's no surprise that
the fuller house cast feels like they're
a family
so when news broke of their co-star
Laurie Lachlan's alleged involvement in
a college bribery scandal Candice had
this to say on The Today Show you know
it's too personal Tyson you never want
to talk about someone that's such a dear
and close friend but I think I've
already said that we are family and we
stand by each other and pray for each
other and we'll always be there for each
other
Laurie is more than just Candace's TV
aunt the two are longtime friends before
the Netflix reboot they shared the
screen on Full House from 1987 to 1995
everybody makes mistakes no parent is
perfect Laurie was arrested for
allegedly paying $500,000 to guarantee
her two daughters Olivia Jade and
Isabella rose admission to the
University of Southern California as
members of the crew team even though
neither was an athlete I want to be
supportive of everything they want to do
but I do want them to have somewhat of a
normal you know finish out of high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't
that I really want that for them in
March it was reported that Laurie was
not expected to return for the fifth and
final season of fuller house at the time
Netflix had no comment when et reached
out about the report I have seriously
loved watching the Tanners on TV again
but it's definitely gonna be a
bittersweet without Aunt Becky
of course Laurie's case is still ongoing
so we'll be here to keep you up-to-date
as news rolls in so be sure to keep it
locked on ET until next time I'm Hallie
Stephens bye for now
[Music]